I sat down with Soleil Moon fry to talk
family holidays and love
you're dating again I want to ask about
this here's what I've been doing lately
which is really beautiful is I have been
taking myself on dates and I feel better
than ever I feel like I have have felt
like a kid again let's talk holidays we
have lots of holidays coming up to you
and the family have special plans or
things that you do uh Traditions yes
absolutely we cook a lot I love what's
your go-to I make a Thanksgiving feast
that is incredible so uh really just
like coming together we do a lot of
baking I bake a lot of Pies when you see
your teenage otters do you see any of
yourself and do they have act the acting
bug are they interested you know my
daughters are amazing my sons are
amazing they're such activists my son
lyric is like such a comedian and a
rapper and Jaggers an amazing performer
poet is this incredible activists and
it's very funny my 14 year old and I
looked so much alike the 46 year old
working mom of four knows being an
advocate for her kids is her biggest job
that's why we teamed up with Soleil and
GSK for more details on the ask to be
sure campaign when I learned about
meningitis B I thought like so many
parents that our kids get vaccinated
when they're younger against meningitis
and did not realize that this was
totally different I was like if I'm if I
didn't know about this that I'm sure
millions of other people didn't know and
although it's an uncommon disease it's
potentially life-threatening and really
this whole campaign has been about going
and talking to your health care
providers you know having the
conversation with your families and
making the choice that's right for you
where where can we uh where can people
get more information they can go to ask
tobiestore.com and carry on the
conversation
[Music]